all right colin
sarah colin where'd you grow up where
are you from originally uh baton rouge
louisiana originally um spent time like
in a lot of little cities around south
louisiana lafayette lake charles and
then uh right outside of nashville
tennessee you moved to tennessee yes sir
how was your childhood you had mom and
dad
uh yeah uh my mom was
undiagnosed bipolar for the majority of
my childhood she finally got medicated
but she was a severe alcoholic
so
her medications obviously did not mix
well
with that
a lot of walking out running out peeling
out
uh drunk and not kind of knowing when
she'd come back
my dad was
an abusive alcoholic
he was
we we grew up
you know in religious households being
from the south and uh
my dad didn't so much go to church as
he was the pulpit
um
so
his punishments were like kneeling on
dry rice and holding the bible above
your head in the corner so like
you know for hours
and
the bible over your head was because if
you if you had your hands free you would
kind of try and push off the ground kind
of alleviate some of the pressure
which then he would beat you until you
could not do that
um
yeah just a whole bunch of
drinking and beating
what kind of kid were you in high school
um i was
i went to two different high schools
i switched back and forth from my mom to
my dad's a lot
and switched schools a lot
because i would get tired of beatings at
my dad's and go to my mom's and i get
tired of the drinking and the craziness
there and i go to my dad's
so i started out at a public school
where i was
a rich white kid and a
majority minority high school
and then i switched
the last two years junior senior year to
a private school
and then i was the poor white kid with a
bunch of rich kids
so
at the public school i was a straight-a
student with no friends and at the
private school
my mom let me have parties um because
she liked to drink so
and she didn't care if it was a bunch of
kids
so we would go uh we'd go to albertsons
and load up got the grocery cart with a
bunch of liquor and beer and whatever
food and we would just roll out and i
would drive the getaway car and
we would steal thousands of dollars
worth of stuff
and i would throw parties so i was the
party house for the last two years my
high school and your mom was encouraging
it oh yeah she was definitely
encouraging it she i think she enjoyed
having a lot of drunk young boys around
uh
yeah there's there's a lot of stuff that
came out all about that kind of [ __ ]
me up sorry
um
she ended up sleeping with one of my
friends on our senior trip
and like she was with my stepfather at
the time who i
because of my relationship with my real
father i looked at my stepfather as my
actual father
and uh
it just really screwed me up when she
like said it out loud in front of a
bunch of my friends that she had slept
with somebody
that we all knew
and i was just like wow
it was like the first time like i knew
relationship i knew relationships were
not what i had always thought they were
by that time
but that was like
it really like shattered
my view of like their relationship you
know
as being like an unshakable thing kind
of like
i always assumed after that they would
eventually split up and
ten years later they did so now they're
now they're divorced
um
so yeah
it was just uh
yeah the last two years was a bunch of
drinking
i didn't i didn't drink so much i i was
a pothead and i sold i sold weed
um
so like it was the house for you know a
bunch of dealing to go on too
my mom was my plug
she she had a guy that went to lsu that
was a medic school student that would
get weed from california
and uh she would give it to me for like
250 an ounce and then i would
sell it and she would you know keep the
lights on
you finished high school
finished high school
went to the community college brcc
and uh i knocked up my college
girlfriend my sophomore year and i
joined the coast guard
i spent six years in the coast guard
she
when i got out of boot camp she uh
her parents they didn't want us together
and they had changed the phone numbers
and locked her away so uh i couldn't get
in touch with her
and i was stationed on a ship in san
diego
so uh
i went to the bering sea and she
finished out her pregnancy
and uh i flew home
still couldn't get in touch with her
ended up having to take her to court a
couple of times
and then on my 21st birthday actually
i got to hold my son for the first time
he was 10 months old
and
then i had to go back
and uh
and that was it i didn't see him for 10
years
she took him
and uh
actually three years ago
it was always
i would always get blacked out drunk on
his birthday so september 28th
that was always a drinking day for me
and uh
the weekend of his 10th birthday
i blacked out for 52 hours straight
i thought i was gonna die but um
i messaged her mom on facebook
and just let her know you know hey i'm
still out here i'm in california living
in hollywood
and uh
you know i still want
my son
and two weeks later i got
a message back from
the mother of my child
and then we started talking
communicating again and
she said she would let me have him have
a relationship with him so
i put in my two weeks notice in my jobs
told my landlord i was leaving
and uh
moved home back to baton rouge
and uh i got to see my son for the first
time in 10 years
and i started building a relationship
seeing him as much as i could he i got
to introduce him to
my grandparents luckily you know i
wanted them to meet him before they died
and then after nine months you know me
and him had finally built a strong
relationship he wanted me to start
picking him up from school
and all that
and uh
it was his birthday
and uh she showed up at my work so he
could get his gifts
and she never let me see him again after
that
that was three years ago
so i got to
have him for a brief
moment
and uh
i mean that's
he's been my only
reason
to live
is to have that opportunity and when she
took him again
i never thought i'd get the chance to
see him as a child
i thought it would be a grown adult i
was meeting
if i survived it
and
to have him gone again it was just
i was back on like i
immediately was back on heroin
i'd never shot it but at that point i
just didn't care anymore so i started
shooting heroin
and then
i was dating a girl and we were shooting
together
and i was
sick and tired of being in baton rouge
for no reason so
i moved back out here
and uh
she started sleeping with our dealer
and we were basically living out of my
car anyway
so i just kicked her out of the car at
his house and
a week later i got my head on collision
so i lost my car
and my house
at the same time and then my job because
i couldn't get there
and i needed the drugs still so i landed
on skid row
because that's where my dealers were so
is that where you're staying now
yeah i live uh
in a tarped-off area at 7th and maple
across my store
i don't like to steal so i'd
spend
most of my nights
dumpster diving and
for shoes and whatever else i can find
to clean up and sell
did you find valuable stuff in the
garbage
yeah i mean it's los angeles there's so
much there's so much excess in the world
that we live in in general in los
angeles like an epicenter for it
so
yes it's crazy the homeless community
down here is like the best tourette the
best dressed homeless community
absolutely ever like i'm in baton rouge
if you're homeless you don't have
you don't have anything you know you
don't have and you don't have anyone
helping you like out here there's people
passing out hot meals three times a day
at least
um you have food
you have an excess of clothing
i don't even
like i i see
hundreds thousands of dollar items that
are closed all the time and i only take
those because
every clothing is so accessible that no
matter what it is people only want to
pay a dollar for it
but like stuff accessories like purses
shoes
you know
especially jewelry stuff like that which
i find a lot of all that
that's the stuff that people actually
will pay more for so that's what i focus
on you go through dumpsters around the
city of la or just downtown uh just down
yeah just down just literally in in this
like in the skid row area i could
imagine if you were in beverly hills or
right oh yeah so one of the wealthier
neighborhoods exactly it's got to be
insane i've never even
like i've just always thought like
i learned that
there's the companies around here
they throw away at night uh truckloads
of stuff that did they didn't sell
and there's certain dumpsters that they
use
and it's all in gated areas so
i jump the gate
and get into those dumpsters i don't
worry about like all the dumpsters
i've learned which dumpsters they use
and that's how i get like i get
you know 300 a pair of jordans that have
never been worn
out of the dumpster and just clean them
off and i can sell them for 20 bucks no
problem
because i know that they're gonna throw
them in that dumpster
um it's crazy it's a much better way of
surviving than yeah boosting or right
and everyone else you know
i've got friends they boost and you know
they go to jail for three days
now they're dope sick
and sitting in a jail cell you know i i
i don't want to risk that
a
but i also i don't you know if you get
even if it's just getting caught by
security i don't like the
you know you're sitting there getting
yelled at by someone younger than you
probably in front of these people it's
just an embarrassing scene and i just
doesn't it's not it's not who i am and
that's not who i want to
you know even live for a moment so
um i try not to do that
i went the other day
with josh but
uh
yeah and we we got caught twice like it
was like
i was like josh that's why i don't do
this because
i don't you know
they actually took the bag i was using
which had a pair of like
brand new
jordans in it that were like limited
edition so like i didn't just not make
money i lost money going doing it and it
was the first time i've done it since
i've been on skid row so it's like okay
so there's my answer no i don't need to
be out here doing this
you get depressed living down here
i do um
[Music]
i've always been i've always had
problems with depression even as a kid
but
i will say that even
and it's weird
and i've got a lot of [ __ ] a lot of
reasons to hate the world whatever
whatever
but
being here has
been the most free i've ever felt
like
you know i get up my want is sleeping i
want
i get money when i need it
or when i want to
you know i don't i'm not
i don't have to answer to anyone i'm not
responsible for anyone but myself
uh and i've never lived that life like
you know i went from being a kid to
being in the coast guard
and then i got out and i'm 26 years old
and i'm married
you know and so i'm responsible for this
like family unit
which i destroyed you know i was a strip
club manager for four years and
as a terrible industry for a marriage
uh
but now i'm not now now i'm not
responsible for any of those people i'm
not responsible
uh
for anything for even for myself hardly
like
it's
it's unfit it's free it's a free feeling
but i i know that it's because i'm so
close to death
i think that's why it feels so freeing
because like i'm almost like
oh you're almost free you're just that
you're just soaking huge all you have to
do is overdose which is almost
impossible at this point i could shoot a
freaking half gram of confetti and
fentanyl and not overdosed so
yeah so that leaves you no drugs to get
right yeah
yeah i mean your body's adjusted to the
fentanyl to the hardest of the heart and
a lot of it so i mean
[Music]
and i mean i don't know i mean i've had
friends hang themselves and shoot
themselves and all that and
i don't know i just
i don't know if i got the balls for it
they're bigger men than i yeah
do you have friends down here
for friends and um in general anywhere
i got some i have some
very good friends back home
uh
i have a a group of friends that are all
brothers
uh and one sister um
and they're my they're more of my family
uh like i spend christmas and
thanksgiving even in high school i'd
spent
christmas and thanksgiving with them
because my family was so
messed up
that uh that they were my way of having
a
a normal family unit um
but like i'm i don't talk to him i
haven't talked to him and
since i've been homeless because i'm i
think i'm so ashamed
of where i've allowed myself to get
like
you can't even imagine what i used to
look like because i've lost
70 pounds in two years like
i was 200 pounds in the coast guard and
i'm like
100 i'm like high school weight now
140 pounds
i mean
you know not worrying about showering or
brushing my teeth just not even caring
about any like hygiene or anything like
that because it's just
why
yeah what does your typical day look
like you wake up and
you need to get
you need to get well
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah usually i wake up
my body wakes me up because it's
needing something um so it doesn't even
it's not really like what's a day look
like it's like
i wake up
because i fell asleep finally
and i probably slept for a day because
it had been three or four days since i'd
slept oh yeah yeah the drugs kind of
take you off the 24 hour yeah and so i
i'll like be up for three or four days
and i'll crash
and i'll finally sleep and i'll hear
because i've got a bunch of stuff that
i've that to sell right
and everybody around has learned
that i do that they know that i do that
and so now there's like all the
scavengers of the scavenger
and they'll they wait until i go to
sleep and they know okay he's comatose
now he's sleeping and i can hear him but
i don't have the energy to wake myself
up and they just come in and clean me
out
so like it happens to everybody here
yeah oh it's yeah it happens everybody
but for me it's like cleaning me out of
like five thousand dollars worth of
merchandise
every four days
so like last night i woke up after
sleeping finally
and like i had
baskets full like shopping carts full of
stuff gone
uh
so today is gonna be a
you know
cleaning up the mess they made and
reorganizing and then tonight starting
back
dumpster diving for the next three days
and trying to
build up the collection again
and i mean it's great like the first
time it happened to me like i was
devastated because i like
i like made a flea market
and it was running like 24 7 and like i
was making like over 100 a day
and then like
i got like cleaned out and i was just
like so depressed i was crying
and and then i like picked myself up
cleaned up the area
and just went back out and started again
and i realized like it's just going to
be a repeating cycle that's just that's
life down here it's
you know and i never stole
you know like you know that's like when
i was in high school yeah i would go
with my mom we would steal from like
walmart albertsons where but from a
human person like i've never been like a
thief
and down here that's the way of life if
you don't if you're not willing to steal
from people then you'll never have
anything because they're going to steal
from you
and
then you're that's your only way of
getting anything back is by stealing so
the other days i woke up someone had
taken my book sack they had a bunch of
phones and a tablet and all some kind of
stuff in it and i got pissed off jumped
on a bike
started going around stealing anything i
could from people just out of anger like
i didn't even care if it was worth
anything i just didn't want them to have
it
um
and you know like that's not who i am
but it's who i've become
out here you know
out of necessity
you just kind of
yeah living on the streets changes you
yeah you have you have to
you have to forget
the the rules of society that you
learned as a kid
and
all the nice cities and all you know
the other day i had a pipe thrown at my
head
because i was white on a certain block
that's the only reason
like i gave a guy a head nod say hello
his response was picking up a pipe and
throwing it at me
the only reason it didn't hit me is
because i saw it coming out the corner
of my eye and moved my head
i've been in like 10 fights in the last
two or three weeks
coming off of seven broken ribs from a
car wreck
so i've re-broken my ribs three
different times in fights
i got in the fight two days ago because
the guy's stolen my shoes and i was
stealing him back
and he hit me from behind with uh
most floor carts on the floor uh dollies
the four wheels
like i put my arm up
in the almost i think he might have like
swollen right here put my arm up luckily
reflected away from my head
so i could feel the dent in my arm bone
so i think he broke my arm
but like again you just
do more drugs and that's the way you're
gonna deal with the pain anyway whether
it's mental emotional or physical
you know so
it's crazy
it really is
what are you afraid of what are you
worried about
um
being stabbed
that's i've had a few knives pulled on
me by people that intended to use them
and like being shot
wasn't doesn't scare me because it's
such a quick
thing
but
being stabbed with a small knife a bunch
of times
it seems very painful and slow and
personal
and
every time i've had someone like have a
knife up to me i've oh that's
that's been
when i'm like oh [ __ ] this person's
about to kill me and it's going to be
really painful
i don't want to die painful
i know i'm going to die
i just don't want it to be like that
but outside of that i mean i've
when i first moved out here and i
started coming down here
i didn't even get a car
like
this area scared me
even being
like i've lived in ghettos before but
this area i could see
the animalistic nature of it especially
at night especially at night
and so i just you know
i certainly wouldn't like let my
girlfriend you know go walk in these
streets and now i walk them every night
by myself
you know sometimes i'll bring a pipe
most of the time i'll forget and try and
find something on the way
uh
but i mean
i've become so numb to
to life
and
in happiness that like
fears almost just
why be scared
scared of what what am i got to lose
a bunch of trash that people threw away
and i'm cleaning up to try and get drugs
uh
it's pitiful hold you 33 33 so you're
still young you could
yeah you could you could put your life
together maybe with another
yeah i was when i got i got in my wreck
when it was a sunday
i was supposed to start school the next
day i was supposed to move into my new
place that day after work
uh
and uh
i drove on my break from work i drove
down here picked up some drugs
was shooting up while i was driving on
the way back to work
uh someone turned in front of me
and i didn't have time to hit the brakes
and uh
and that my girlfriend had wrecked my
car a month prior so the seat belts were
broken and the airbags had already
deployed
so i hit them going 50 miles an hour
head-on and my face
hit the windshield my chest the steering
wheel
and broke most of my ribs and the scar
on my forehead
took a chunk out of my forehead
uh
and that was it like i no longer was
going to be able to get to school
i was no longer able to get to work
wasn't able to get in my new place
didn't have my the cops left my phone in
the car so
i couldn't contact anybody
my roommate not anybody to let them know
what was going on
i just woke up in the hospital
they hadn't bandaged me up or nothing i
was just sitting there with the blood
all over me still
so i pulled the
ivs and everything off my arms
demanded that they let me out
they let me go and i had to walk six
miles back to my friend's place
and uh i stayed there for the first
couple of days
um
but i knew i needed to get you know the
drugs especially with broken ribs now so
i just uh
and i couldn't stay in the south bay and
you know
be stealing from like you're gonna like
i had already gone to jail
uh i already went to jail one time
down there uh in hermosa beach
so like they're not gonna let you sit on
the beach down there and shoot up and
steal [ __ ] like that's just not gonna be
happening over there
so the cops told me to go to like doc
wild or venice
but i was like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna go
downtown skid row yeah like you can do
whatever you want here yeah it's the
easiest place like
it might be the most dangerous but yeah
but i mean you know whatever worst case
scenario i die and
the problem solved do you feel like you
have some kind of death wish
at this point i do uh
i think for
for years and years and years my son was
like the focal the focus
point of my life
and i looked at it as
i'll have him one day and that's why
i'll survive
and then i think
get
having the opportunity to have him
was just so overwhelming
[Music]
and such and just like a dream come true
like like i just never thought it would
happen and then it happened
and then losing him again which i just
never thought
i never thought she would do that like
even though like we i we went to his
therapist together like and the
therapist was even sad like obviously
it's not even an option to take to to
push me out again because that would
[ __ ] him up so much
and i don't even
his mom just doesn't care like it's not
about him
it's about
you know it's about her
and
you know
and her she's power huh she's you know
she just wants she's angry at you
absolutely
um
and i don't really know why like i mean
i didn't do this you know i i
i always wanted to be there i always you
know i joined the coast guard with the
intent of being a family unit you know
and being together
uh
you know her family did it
and
and then and then her and then she did
it
and
so i don't really know why she has any
reason to be angry at me
nearly as much as i have reason to be
angry at her but
it really doesn't matter because at the
end of the day i don't have him again
and when that happened it just took
all
will to live away like
i was trying so hard to like walk a
straight line and be this person for him
to look up to and be like that's so i
wanted to be
i knew i could never be my stepfather
uh
but i wanted to try to be
like that
like that same like
juxtaposition you know like
you could see the similarities there
like oh he's looking to me and saying
that's my father you know
and with some with some type of
pride and not being like some dirt bag
on skid row stealing and doing drugs
uh
and i was trying i was doing it and you
know
and now i'm this
you know now i'm the the exact opposite
of what
i ever would want to be
for him
like this
i think the most terrifying idea
would be to still be alive
in a few years and him find me here
like this
i think that's would be
the
the culmination of all my real fears
all right well colin thank you so much
for sharing your story
no problem i hope you get your
get in contact with your son again
somehow
and get yourself clean somehow that'd be
great
one day good luck thank you
you